we now are aware of more than 100 US
service members who have been diagnosed
with traumatic brain injuries these are
those same traumatic brain injuries that
Donald from previously described as not
serious headaches all as a result of
that January 8th Iranian missiles attack
on the military base in Iraq the
Pentagon said yesterday the exact number
is 109 servicemembers who have been
diagnosed the most recent number was 64
but remember that the number initially
started far lower at 10 which was never
really a believable number and we'll get
to that in a moment
now we're not saying these hundred and
nine brain injuries are the most serious
brain injuries some are mild about 70%
of the servicemembers are or are soon
going to be back to work but remember
that Donald Trump Donald Trump wrote
these off as headaches cadet bone spurs
deciding that these are mere headaches
remember this oh I want to play though
here's how the president described it
when he was asked about these injuries I
heard that they had headaches and a
couple of other things but I would say
yeah and I can report it is not very
serious and Republicans actually ran
interference for Trump here is sick vile
Senator Tom cotton truly one of the
worst saying well you know Trump is not
really dismissing them as headaches he's
describing them as headaches and that of
course is perfectly fine to do so I
think veterans groups are calling for
the president to apologize should he
apologize for calling it nothing okay he
just described he's not dismissing their
injuries he's describing he said their
headaches and not very serious
I think he's describing their injuries
he's not dismissing their injuries head
injuries can be on any wakes I don't
consider them very serious well that's
like saying that having a flesh wound is
not very serious veterans groups and I
know you're a veteran and I know you'll
be better suffered from TBI as do I
don't you think it's serious and that
the president may need to apologize I
mean if it isn't if they are in fact all
these injuries are not serious if
they're on the less serious side of the
scale than the severe traumatic side of
the
scale the president is just describing
what happened he was not dismissing them
nice people right so when we talk about
a brain injury TBI traumatic brain
injury it can vary in severity but it's
not a headache that we know for sure
sometimes they happen in sports we know
football this is a big issue hockey it
can be a big issue
there's even questions about younger
kids using their head to hit a soccer
ball potentially causing a sort of a
similar dynamic it can happen in a car
accident when a victim's a passenger's
head hits the windshield of the vehicle
and they happen to people in the
military the most notable thing here is
that from day one we knew that they
weren't giving us the real number they
said well it's 10 or 11 and that number
was clearly BS and the phrasing of how
they gave us that first number suggested
that it was not 10 or 11 we knew it
couldn't be the right number and then it
became something like maybe 35 and then
we had the number 64 and now the number
is a hundred and nine because they are
lying they are lying all the time about
everything period and by the way we hear
about service member injuries because
we're hearing about it from the US
Pentagon and the number is now 109
obviously there were also non-american
non service members injured and we
simply haven't heard about that
civilians and others concussed by the
missiles that resulted from Donald from
cessation ation of Kasseem soleimani
there were known to be hundreds of
people in the area if not more they
weren't all service members and we may
never even know the full number as it
applies here my question to you is do
you think that the average Trumpets who
believes the lies they are told by this
administration never gets like a shot of
shame or a shot of humiliation or a
tinge of embarrassment from realizing
that they've been duped that they've
been had that they've been bamboozled on
everything right and now we're talking
about brain injuries and Trump
dismissing them as headaches but it
could be about the wall it could be
about taxes it could be about trade it
could be about growth it could be about
whatever do they ever feel that
tinge of something or will they never
get it and there's something I alluded
to this earlier and I think it bears
repeating here there's something in here
that is similar between Trump's lies to
the people who get tricked into
following a cult leader who says again
the world's ending on April 21st or
there will come a day where we all need
to drink poisoned kool-aid or whatever
the case may be and then the prophecy
fails or the justification falls flat
but they still follow the Dear Leader
because they either somehow rationalize
it or they put for some people it's that
they've put so much of their own
identity in with whatever ideology and
the term ideology in some cases is not
the right one with whatever talking
points have been presented to them
associated with this leader and they can
never back out and behavioral psychology
might call it a cognitive dissonance of
sorts in the cult world they might call
it brainwashing there are different
words that would apply depending on how
you see this but increasingly the cult
analysis I'm including we had a guest on
Steven Hassan who has been studying this
quite a bit increasingly the cult
analysis is the most appropriate one for
talking about what it is that is going
on with the average trumpets tell me
what you think is it more cultish is it
more a cognitive dissonance is it out of
ignorance is it something else
altogether I want to hear from you maybe
via Twitter at D Pakman do you feel like
you just don't have enough time to
become as intellectually well-rounded as
you would like to be that there are just
not enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about 8 bucks a month
but you can try it for free for a week
and get 25% off a subscription when you
go to blankest comm slash Pakman what
blink is does is take thousands of
popular nonfiction books and condense
them into either text or audio that you
can read or listen to in just 15 minutes
and what you get is all of the most
important ideas and information
from the book imagine being able to
listen to an entire non-fiction book in
the amount of time it takes you to drive
or walk home from work I just finished
listening to the way we eat now by bee
Wilson whose work I've recommended to
you before super interesting look at how
the global food system works and impacts
the way that we live
blink is has totally transformed how I
consume information I love it of course
I read a book in its entirety when I can
but there are simply just so many books
that I want to read and would not have
the time for if it weren't for blink
Asst they have books on politics
economics philosophy science you name it
you can try it out yourself totally free
for a week and get 25% off if you decide
to subscribe just by going to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video like the
rest of us I bet you're going into 20/20
thinking about what you didn't get
around to in 2019 and your goals for the
new year if you want to work towards
being your best self in 2020 understand
more about the world around you and make
sure that your time is well spent then
blink astiz for you